what's the difference between a globally  distributed database with strong  consistency and one without  predictability no missing data no out of  sync data reliable accuracy every time  with Google Cloud spanner the  horizontally scalable relational  database your data is available when  it's needed and it's consistent no  matter where your users are  it's a predictability that you can  depend on with other databases offering  less than strong consistency your data  may or may not be there when your users  need it most  or even worse it may not be accurate  Google Cloud spanner gives you all of  the benefits of a relational database  simplicity speed and data integrity  while scaling to handle even the most  challenging of transactional workloads  Google Cloud spanner never choose  between scale and data accuracy again